pink if someone had told you when you
were a little girl I know you were the
one little kid who said like almost from
the time you were you know a baby I'm
gonna be a star but would you have
believed that you'd be going at a tour
at this point I mean I haven't it's a
big imagination but no right not this
big do you ever burn out on it I mean
you said you loved doing it but again
oh God another not creatively creatively
I am always performance wise and
songwriting and singing I'm always
trying to be better there was a point
last tour
with two kids the first year of that
tour was
impossible and it it shaved off a couple
years of my life and it it broke my
heart and it made me question everything
why was it so difficult that tour we
couldn't get well my daughter had the
flu my son had hand foot and mouth
disease in his
fingernails and toenails are falling off
and and then they have the flu again and
then I have the flu and then I have
norovirus and then I'm in the hospital
and then there's newspapers saying that
I'm [__] off on a beach somewhere and
I'm literally like dying and I'm trying
to get well
and I take it so seriously if you look
at my track record I never cancel I've
gone on stage bleeding with separated
shoulders right I I never cancel and and
I just felt so beat down and you get
makes me want to cry like you get you
get into a hotel room at 3am and your
kids are tired and you're like what am I
doing
what am I doing this is why women don't
do this this is why moms don't do this
this is impossible
and then you just get up and you go to
you get on stage and you do it
I I think you're crying for yourself too
because I'm crying for my babies because
I just remember like oh this is this is
not cool guys I meant I remember I came
into um this is why it's so important
that we're all so close because we all
have lives outside of this and we've
been together for so long you know we've
grown up together I mean I've been with
you Jason for 20.
22 years
wow um
you know we go through stuff and
sometimes we have to take a break off
they take a break because it's just
untenable I came into a dressing room
with my dancers where we kind of work
out together before the show and I just
lock just crumpled and Tracy one of my
dancers she goes
I'll be right back and she came with a
stack of plates and we're in this arena
in this bathroom and she's like right
right everything write it on the plates
and then break them and I was like
no
I'm gonna clean it up
Virgo Virgo took over no then the poor
Arena staff is gonna have to clean it up
that's just rude Tracy she's like
[__] break it and I was like and then
people were running in like are you
murdering each other with spoons what is
happening and I'm like well you know you
make me think let's go do this you're
right about the people you tour with
because I mean you're spending so much
of your life with them but there's also
this thing that I always thought it's
much harder to be a mom and hold your
family together
dudes go on the road and they're like
they got their wives at home watching
the kids in three weeks yeah yeah see in
three weeks and in a way maybe you kind
of like if I never had kids it'd be so
much easier to have a full-time music
career and stay in it and care about it
it's almost impossible to do with a with
a family yeah yeah there's two parts to
that I've had to explain to a lot of the
men around me that that and I said it in
my documentary too there's no door I
walk out of and go to work my kids come
with me I don't even go to the bathroom
alone they still sleep in my bed
and I love that and I would give all of
this up for them because I had so much
of this I signed my record deal when I
was 16 years old I've been on my own
since I was 15. I've lived so much life
and I've checked a lot of my boxes here
and it's unbelievable what we get to do
together it's it's as Justin would say
unbelievable and and and having a family
was important to me and being a mom is
by far my my favorite thing I've ever
gotten to do these kids are [__]
delicious I want to squeeze them until
their heads pop off right I won't Child
Protective Services I will not but
I just love them so much and they get to
grow up with all these incredible people
they get to tour the world and these are
their family they grow they know these
people they know these people's children
it's just it's incredible didn't some
industry Dude tell you at some point
that if you had kids your career would
be over I mean uh yeah pretty much
pretty much yeah it's not a good idea
why because you wouldn't be sexy to the
audience you wouldn't be like well you'd
be a mom and then you'd be you how do
you tour and how do you keep doing this
and then you won't want to do this is
the rebel in you go [__] you I'm gonna
have kids and then I'm gonna prove to
you that I can't have a career because I
don't know if I thought that outright I
think maybe but for me it's like this is
important to me in my life and and
ambition and this carrot over here I've
tasted it and it's it's slightly sweet
it's sweet but I feel like I can find a
bigger carrot
foreign